[Music]
the moment a couple ties the knot if
they don't already have children the
first thing most people ask is when are
you having kids the pressure we put on
couples to procreate is quite perplexing
as is the supreme value we place on the
need for those children to be biological
TV presenters lewis and hannah Van Jones
recently made headlines for spending 80
thousand pounds on 15 rounds of IVF
fortunately their last round and final
embryo produced a beautiful healthy baby
boy but their's is a rare success story
most people do not have the means or the
resilience to withstand 15 rounds of IVF
and are often left childless if they
can't conceive therefore surely we
should encourage more people to adopt
even those who can conceive naturally
which is why I welcome a 45 million
pound boost from the government to
adoption services to help reduce a
number of children in care waiting for a
permanent home we need to place more
value on raising a child than birthing a
child having the same DNA is not the
be-all and end-all love is what matters
most I despair when I saw the figure
76,000 children and care which is a
shocking amount as a small town and I
also despair quite often when I read
that people spending vast sums of money
on having surrogate children because why
don't they just adopt so I was adopted I
was 2 and a half I'd been in a Catholic
Children's Home in Cheltenham run by the
nuns mercifully I don't have a
recollection of it but I was adopted by
a work very nice working-class set of
parents they already had three children
of their own biological children mum had
lost a couple of kids in labour but the
priest came to the school and said
there's lots of children who need homes
I know you haven't got much my dad
worked for British Leyland my mum works
for a warehouse but they adopted me they
brought me up as their own although I
don't look the same as my siblings I'm a
bit slimmer and more high but they that
nobody could say that my mum and dad
treated me any differently to my brother
and two sisters who still I see all the
time mum and dad are with me now anymore
but they were incredibly proud of how it
worked out and I would say to people
watching it isn't that scary because you
can be loved just as much as if I was a
birth brother or sister and and if they
hadn't adopted me God knows how many as
I could have been there because two and
a half is quite late on most people want
to be adopted at five weeks you can
mould them very early on and and and
it's just the obvious way to do it
and I just know a colleague the other
day who's adopted two kids who are 5 and
7 it's not easy
can I ask has it obviously there are ups
and downs any sibling reaction I've
experienced that myself with blood
sibling yeah lots of things so are there
moments at the down times where the fact
that it's distinction between birth and
sibling and and blood siblings raised at
a moment of weakness by anyone or is it
as that never been an issue you know in
all the times I fought with my brother
two sisters it never cropped up yeah
kids at school were cruel because kids
are cruel and they would often say well
you're not really Epirus you know
because I'm come from Irish stock but
you know oh annex well my foot I was
born I was Patrick until I was 2 and
I'll and and I wrote a letter to the
Daily Mirror which I always wanted to be
a journalist when it was announced that
the law was changing so that adopted
kids could track down their birth
parents Marjorie Proops wrote a column
in them Daily Mirror saying why she
thought this was a good idea and I read
a letter to the Daily Mirror saying why
I thought it was a bad idea
pointing out that in my view blood isn't
thicker than water
my real mum and dad are the ones who
adopted me I don't say that did I go to
my grave to find you you're always
curious you're always curious you think
about it it's it's it's another story
it's interesting appears they are very
good friends as long as I've known him
but one of my biggest regrets is that
when I was about five my parents who
couldn't have any more kids naturally
said to me when I was five you know how
would you feed if we adopted a child and
and I said no and it's one of the
biggest regrets among because I wanted
my mom and dad to myself but I couldn't
conceive I was an only child and I
really they couldn't have any more kids
in they wanted more but yeah but but and
it's a huge regret of man that that I
was so against it but anyway and they
want to do it because of you said yeah
they didn't do it because I think but
but what we're gonna have to do because
they've all these kids waiting to be
adopted I've been writing stories about
this adoption process since I was a
young reporter and and if we have to
make it's a long it's a torturous
invasive your process it can take two a
half years or more than that and and a
lot of times were the best will in the
world who it we've got big heart they
can't take it better 203 yeah but I
wanna ask you a question there's that
there's a lot of bein looping you mean
yeah there's a lot of a lot of bein kids
one of the biggest you know that the
mixed-race they're the ones that I think
there's a phrase it's it's they're lower
slower rate of adoption and but the
authorities are stopping those kids
going to white families I think they
what do you think about that I think
tomates the family should be about that
there's a loving family doesn't matter
what casket well the thing is the the
issue with that is particularly sort of
in the 70s and 80s where you had a lot
of it was mainly mixed-race children yes
and who were adopted by white parents
often raised in communities where they
were the only person of color yes and
there were all sorts of problems
associated with that and I think that if
we are going to change the law so that
because as it stands now one of the
parents has to be something other we're
going to change that law then what we
have to do is make sure that that couple
has people of color in their social
circle and it actually makes a point of
teaching that child about its culture
because there are all sorts of issues
that come that you can only understand
if you are if I get that but if there's
no it's very much you said it's a very
difficult process there's a woman called
dr. Kawa London who was the chief
executive of the children's charity
coram
who disagrees with you it's actually not
an arduous or lengthy process but it is
a since
one a process designed to enable people
to find out what has happened for the
children that are waiting for adoption
and whether adoption is right for them
but normally the process would take just
a little under a year and you would come
forward to an agency near you to get the
help and support from the social workers
to prepare yourself and then to be
matched with a child okay I mean on my
friends and family and there was quite a
few adopted children some have been
incredibly successful as adoptions a few
have been disasters because the kids are
very difficult and many right nobody
tells you about that and the support
afterwards after doctrine is pretty poor
and what do you do if suddenly you've
got a child that is an incredibly
difficult violent gets involved and I
would say it's well though a birth child
can turn out to be very different that
you know you can't send your it's your
birth chart back but that's the whole
point of this money is it is also to
provide support post adoption yes you I
well I won't touch from Carol's point
about bein adoptions as well but let's
first hear from sue Armstrong brown a
chief executive of adoption communicate
one in ten adoptions now go to single
adopters about the same proportion go to
same-sex adopters so people from all
walks of life are very much encouraged
to come forward to adopt the sad thing
is that the numbers of children waiting
in care for adoption around are
outnumbering many times over the numbers
of people coming forward to adopt and
that's something that is urgent to
address we're glad to see the government
investing some more money into
encouraging adoption and it's very
important that equal attention is given
to supporting these placements after the
children come home to their adoptive
families now she don't say more needs to
be done in terms of the fact that there
are a number of children waiting now
your question about bein adoptions so my
father is married not to my mother and
his wife my father's wife
from Pakistan and therefore English is a
second language and doesn't she doesn't
primarily speak English at home to my
father they speaking ordered or Punjabi
with each other now they tried to adopt
recently some Syrian refugees or I think
it was even foster so don't quote me on
which one it was but they were
eventually when I went through the
process so it doesn't seem to be as easy
as one may assume because they will
reject it and the reason for the refusal
so it even checks the boxes on the whole
baby situation and you'd expect Syrian
refugees also Muslims you know that they
would need home desperately but the
reason that they apparently gave and I
don't know the details was that her
English wasn't good enough now my
father's English is affluent and and I
just wonder what you know whether that
if one of the parents my dad speaks
fluent English and the other one is an
immigrant anyway here English by
definition won't be that good and
they're in South End where you know it's
a majority white population they're
gonna be speaking English at school
anyway
and I just felt when I heard that news
that you know Syrian refugees need a
home and I don't understand how these
things were worked out why that was so
factor age so they would have also taken
education so she said only this week
that they've got to change some of these
presumptions it's after that that middle
class Indian couple one that High Court
case they've want damages because they
said we've got to stop presumptions
about race and income because the
important thing is to get these kids
seventy six thousand i repeating care
that's into loving try to overturn the
race he tried to overturn that law when
he was in power and didn't get to do
that but what is disturbing as well is
you know there's a 20 percent return
rate on a doctor yeah so so they're put
into it so they so the social services
don't tell the parents the full story
the parent can't handle it so the poor
kid gets thrown back into the system
probably ruined for life actually but
then you look at the social workers well
when you think if you're the social
worker in this you're spending your life
trying to get these children adopted you
are bound in the end to paint arose your
pictures and you get the child into a
home yes well coming up on the pledge
why I'll be Bangor Bob for the brexit
bonds
[Music]